let me get you some Twitter okay I
should have done this ahead of time okay
you know what [ __ ] it all right you
ready for this you ready for this black
ops all right
or did you or did you set it up no let's
go let's do it cuz I'm a killer I'm a
killer doing it for Mandela wait how
does it sound on the thing I know I
don't know what I'm doing up so late
y'all
cuz I'm playing these games like I got
the green screen setup yeah I don't know
about this you don't know about how I'm
going I'm going
sick with it but you can't leak watch I
think you played duo change it to do oh
yeah so let's go y'all
testing how's the sound stream you know
I got my good mic on I want to make sure
I sound good know what everybody do okay
we got it
y'all don't know I'm a Green Beret
killer on this I'm a killer oh god I'm
not voting against Tom Brady like I'm
done voting against yeah that's it
there's no more voting against Tom Brady
y'all sounds good everybody says sounds
good good yeah I'm on our Xbox this is
the Xbox situation right now
we gonna play a little black what if we
win right now wouldn't it be so dope
yeah we would never forget look at the
graphics on this is Cameron this game is
beautiful yeah guys I wouldn't
I'm just I'm so done voting against Tom
I'm not
I'm not gonna vote against Tom Brady
until he's dead you know I mean I'm not
even talking about retired till he's
dead cuz that dude just fires away man
he makes everybody around him better I'm
just done even though I wanna I want to
go to Vegas and bet on the Rams because
I just think their defense is better
than Casey but Dan I don't just don't
know but I think bail checks gonna
scheme his ass off and that's gonna be
it you know what I mean
how are you just gonna play forever
mmm black out okay where we gonna go
[Applause]
let's go frakking Tower Franco I don't
know what you always say [ __ ] like I
know where that is
did we already drop is it right here
yeah yeah we we truly are the worst wait
wait am I gonna make it to it where is
it yeah oh oh I see oh okay oh I got you
I got you good right here yeah there's
so many people here dude okay I'm gonna
go don't worry I'm here oh you're here
oh god there's no guns in here oh my god
I can't stand this wait wait wait okay I
found a gun oh I hate these kind of guns
though son you're telling me and your
over okay there you are
oh [ __ ] was it that's you dude my car
you're the worst how'd you get that
big-ass gun I went up on that roof or
this roof saw the roof I don't want a
shotgun I hate shotguns I'm going in
this building over here oh my god yeah
but I'm eliminated now you want to get
him okay this is what happens guys when
you play with somebody they don't you
know you should I needed to get a gun to
spectate
oh did you die I die okay well there you
go guys there you go you are the worst
to play wit coke is so right about you
whatever guys stop sending me messages
so you can see your name on the screen
please this is this game is so
infuriating
alright we need to go like far away you
know what I mean not in the heart in the
thick of it I like to go like super far
well we were number 39 I guess that's
not that bad that's pretty bad yo yes
the stream is live QT 14 I'm not going
to talk to you Shawn Smith people like I
love with people on the stream or like
you suck like duh that's why you know
[Laughter]
yes this is like oh my god I'm not even
I'm not even oh what happened I lost
connection to the host who did you did
yeah
oh my god so Mike am I gonna be by
myself I'm by myself
oh yeah yeah I know why they know how
terrible you are dude I'm in the same
building that we just died in who's that
bad oh [ __ ] I just got kicked what just
happen you invite all the other thing is
we gotta add moderators to your YouTube
gaming life what do you mean so like you
know if people in chat are being too
rowdy or being racist or same time show
oh well actually I actually have that
like I have like a like I can if
somebody system a curse word it doesn't
show up I can yeah so people think that
things going in it I I allow it or not
okay yeah I don't hate dogs I love dogs
I just don't like dogs on airplanes
there's a time and place for a [ __ ]
dog no I haven't got read dead yet Bobby
told me he was gonna buy me Red Dead and
he never did so he on his podcast he's
all like I'm gonna buy this for you you
know and then you know he's all like
look at all these people can i be a mod
to be a moderator no you cannot be a
moderator dude all right there we go
everybody keeps asking about anthem what
is anthem what kind of game is it it's
like a shooter it is you get like in
these suits
oh my guys like moderations are for
snowflakes
[Laughter]
sorry Joshua sorry Joshua that's not
gonna get into the stream yes two people
are testing it out putting in curse
words and it's getting hidden sorry Bo
sorry you're not getting that through
okay I wish that this stuff you pick up
here it like you know you could take it
with you yeah that'd be great
then it's like Hunger Games you know
what I mean Oh
this [ __ ] is trying to fight me you
trying to fight me girl you should see
this is not good for the me2 movement
well you just have girls just walk it up
and punching people look at this girl
watch out oh look she's oh she's rough
oh girl in the face yeah you can't just
walk up and hit a black guy and hit a
girl this isn't right this girl this
girl is [ __ ] me up man [ __ ] get back
home
this girl look at this girl she is look
at this girl y'all this girls beatin my
ass but I can't say anything this is a
me-too situation I'm sure bad oh now I
know our Asian guy is hitting me okay so
now I'm getting beat up by Asian dude
and two girls see crazy rich Asians and
the me to movement people are crazy
[Laughter]
this message is held for review see it's
great somebody said somebody said clip
that Griffin is hitting a woman I'm
going to lighthouse I start over here oh
do some people are already going to
lighthouse look how many people are
going all lighthouse oh my god dude just
usually there's a guy right there look
look at that guy he's gonna make it
there before us
oh not me he's not gonna make it I'm
going through this window oh [ __ ]
I'm gonna get [ __ ] up dude oh there's
a gun there's a gun there's a gun you
know what I gotta close this door is
that you crashing through windows yeah I
just got in so I can get it done I just
can't anything again again Oh guys
stupid
dude I don't know if anybody's down -
yes yeah yeah I'm coming down the stairs
I'm coming up the stairs okay there's a
backpack over here I already got it okay
this isn't bad not bad well we in the
zone - are we in the zone
okay oh yeah we stay here okay I'm gonna
go up to the top see what I can find up
here dude
Oh somebody in there oh my god you
stupid pieces look at you oh my god
going up to the top can you jump off and
your parachute thing will start oh you
got a 50 Cal nice I'm at the top
no I don't think you can there's there's
two people here that we were virus awful
god
these guys are trying to come up I'm not
having oh my god dude this is so scary
this is like waiting to die where's your
door are they coming from weird though
they're moving around downstairs I can
hear them on my headset yeah I can hear
them too I thought they were coming up
the stairs oh my god dude this is I hear
them well this is like I'm gonna die oh
my god
okay this is like a hundred people are
watching it look at the safety okay am I
in the circle still where am I oh god
I'm still in this work oh this yeah
you're still in the circle soon a circle
okay
you could lame it out I don't know
either
oh [ __ ]
that scared me I gotta go real slow wait
let me get some more of this do you
think they left they might have you can
look out the window to see if they're
swimming away oh my god I hear a boat
let me get some 50 Cal okay you can't
get out this window hmm hold on watch
the dock oh [ __ ]
you fine you're fine you're my god you
should be able to jump off this in
there's people moving in front of you
where they're across your right to the
right over there across the beach you
see that guy in front of you no 127 he's
right there I saw moving dude going down
the hill okay you need to chill out okay
you're not helping okay
so you can't jump off in this you'll die
right yeah probably
oh my god yeah probably just go down
lower and then jump I believe in you
Griffin no you don't you want me to
dodge so you can play I feel it I feel
your energy right now no I know I feel
your energy
I figure I hope you died so I could get
back into game energy
alright guys I'm gonna get the chat will
fast I know I'm letting some I some the
Rambo of comedy Oh what is that okay
this is your stuff did you die right
here yeah openness oh [ __ ]
people [ __ ] what am i doing why did I
jump okay ha wait how do you get that
take everything I don't even know if I
took everything you could just hold X on
it I didn't have a lot of stuff oh you
know what's crazy I'm still in the
circle yeah oh this is you could jump
out right there and you'll be fine I'm
gonna jump out right there oh this is so
scary
maybe we should play zombie no zombies
born I just do what is that like are
people coming should I keep you know
shooting and [ __ ] yeah it's from across
the water on cargo of the boat what if
the one I'm in the circle and like the
end game is active walked at the
lighthouse yeah that's not gonna happen
it's probably gonna end up in like
you're a god negative all the time okay
I'm sorry
okay here we go okay wait wait wait wait
wait wait oh I shouldn't open the door
because I don't even know where to go
look should I swim over to this boat oh
my god I wonder if I should swim over
there on you can't oh my god this is a
nightmare
wait somebody's shooting at me is your
boat over here let me see if there's a
boat no I'm not gonna oh [ __ ] there's no
duh
just just go to the [ __ ] boat
you just relax yourself and let me play
you know you don't want to died
instantly oh no you know what I'm gonna
have to swim it I'm gonna have to swim
it I'm not gonna drown my gay ass dude
it's someone air get some air girl oh
[ __ ] oh wait wait oh god I hurt myself
grounded
what if she gets tired
do you people the straight-shooting this
[ __ ] over here man okay [ __ ] you get on
this big ship you don't come around oh
sure
well if I just chilled right here the
whole time
god I'm just [ __ ] swim is so loud
it's like you know can you get a little
green beret swimming damn she's crimson
do you hear how loud this women is like
this is oh my god okay how's the sound
okay you know I'll let this one go
somebody said Navy SEAL [ __ ] see I must
show that one you know I get to decide
you know I mean y'all I get to decide
wait where's the chat I love the chats
chats go get to safety
dammit wait am I still in the same gang
gang oh I'm still in the circuit I mean
I can't believe how loud this [ __ ]
stroke is like this is ridiculous
disagree bright still school school
school oh shoot you know me Godley like
everybody in the whole city can hear me
swimming up oh now she's doing it check
her out someone just said they finish
your song for you oh good cuz I had a
good episode today and I had a good
theme song today and then my guest today
was freestyling on the theme song okay
sheesh okay all right I'm in this circle
but tandace is dangerous okay there's a
there's a ladder right there do you
think I should go for it
oh my god do you hear how loud this
[ __ ] is swimming Oh God okay
here you go
all right y'all all right oh [ __ ] oh
look at this oh my god you know what
sucks is I'm just gonna die like this I
hope you did okay here we go all right
I don't need that Oh take that yeah oh
why here's some people shooting this is
a good place to be though okay see but
somebody could wake the other gun I have
I have no [ __ ] mods on my guns I'm
gonna scope nothing huh Shh just not
that wait let me see
oh my god I'm knee-deep in the circle
right now oh my god I'm so far from the
circle that's actually a good thing
though I'm gonna go slow
you should start moving the circles
gonna move really fast
okay relax god damn yeah just let you
know I just wanna make sure that like
there's nobody around is that okay with
you yeah yeah yeah I should have gotten
to that why can't you get into that
truck you look down gasps Sam I see we
got here paranoia yeah no that's good
that you should take that you don't
he'll be here there's only 26 people
left
oh my god I just I pressed the wrong
button okay that is the worst that's
like literally the worst gameplay ever
like I can't I'm gonna go to the killcam
I'm gonna get a replay okay okay go into
the bathroom I'm thinking something's up
and then I light a Molotov cocktail and
Lomas oh my god dude oh my god that was
the worst [ __ ] ever
okay all right guys that was like a
little warm-up you know I made so stop
hating like the whole [ __ ] stream is
laughing at me [ __ ] y'all
okay how about that you're not I mean
all y'all can go kiss my ass oh my god
okay that was
someone's like DVD okay that's one we're
gonna do thank you we're not gonna die
okay yeah this one work coming in strong
okay damn it dude what was that
embarrassing I pressed the wrong button
guys it's not my fault
okay so stop tripping and acting like
you understand you know I just I just
pressed the wrong button I pressed a row
let's go - we could good either nuketown
we can go to the states there you want
to try going - no ray
what do you what do you want to go
Griffin who's hitting me now let's
Pikachu everybody that's what I'm
playing with I didn't hit anyone who's
got you from worse party no wait we do
this I said okay there you go so now I
can turn off close this all right I
dropped you dropped a little bit marker
yeah but I don't understand what where
is the blue marker in comparison to oh I
see what you're going I see you where we
going dude why would you pick a plate oh
my god I'm going to this house I did
here I owe you this place is fine
[ __ ] please let there be a gun in here
what why would they drop this [ __ ] and
not a gun oh here we go okay boom boom
son there's two backpacks over here
we're on that two backpacks outside door
sir are you eating with me you are any
guns where you're at
no oh [ __ ] I almost shot dude you almost
got blown the [ __ ] up you do not jump
inside and without saying that's me god
damn it
okay hey let's go in this house right
over here there's gotta be a gummy okay
I got a gun freaking shot you pissed off
well there's a bunch of houses here
gotta close the door behind us dude oh
yes I'm taking this take that that's
hella good okay let's see you some nice
comment oh yeah this is dope this is
dope y'all if you want to watch yeah
there you go somebody put up a stream of
our worst for our team in my youtube so
they could see that okay um do we need
some like armor there's no armor and she
liked having here
I'll start what is this no sure what
there's someone yours oh my god damn it
okay who's this oh wait here well we
here we'll wait here I'm scared [ __ ]
with me hey oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] they're
coming they're coming Shh get ready to
shoot Oh beautiful
I put them over safety here they come
here they come
coming in here you ready okay ready
oh this is beautiful
I got skull course we can't even hear me
here they come
this is it I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna
shoot my gun so I can maybe oh [ __ ]
oh my god I got you I got you I'm
reviving you oh okay that was so bad
and this is it I can't stand it we like
have video evidence of how bad this [ __ ]
is you know it's some guy that made a
song for you wants to play with oh so
you want to do quads
oh no mad at me up to you yes we can ask
some people in no I need to move this
over okay
all right hold up a second corner six
bar
you fix my thing alright let me add this
guy off he's not a weirdo there we go
of course hey the the guy who added me
that uber dudes and me and in fact when
it [ __ ] her name that's terrible
I mean mine why did we stay in that room
we should just bolt it outside I know I
mean that was terrible I know this was
dead it was traumatizing this whole
thing is traumatized I'm really sorry
guys the whole [ __ ] is traumatized
you don't think I'm feel traumatized
yeah all right he's I'm joining this
party I'll invite you I am loading a
full clip out the window out of fear no
no no you don't get to chat yet let's
see how he does first okay okay just
chat look he customized his character
maybe we should Adam we might be good
are you ready to start are you gonna add
them to the party
I guess Adam to the party yeah maybe we
should see if anybody else is out there
there wants to play I don't know no no
this is this is so frustrating
yeah what the [ __ ] what is up hey Mike
what's up guys don't start your nonsense
you sound fine I'm talking too much
again play threes or yeah I know I know
yeah I'm talking [ __ ] each level 80 and
I'm level 5 you know what stream
y'all need to mind your [ __ ] business
is what y'all need to do okay okay now
you guys check out I was playing with me
oh yeah and said track frame and a
stream on my phone dude I cannot believe
dude I can't believe I threw a Molotov
cocktail on myself in a bathroom in a
bathroom too that's ridiculous
I love that you watch the game
afterwards yeah everybody's even here a
play on PC just mind your business thank
you for everyone that watched along with
- this is riffing game man yeah I don't
know well cuz we cuz he added you know
you added him and then he added me yes I
start and even okay okay yeah guys my
name is spelled with a k e RI k okay if
you know me in the chat ya talkin to me
Evie's spelling me all right
er I see you're getting bad yeah you get
blocked
[Laughter]
we sure
Pikachu do you stream a lot you like
stream a lot yeah I try to see you
around who do you play with I play with
coke yeah I mean yeah if you want to see
a stream will be on here on Twitch and
on YouTube yeah we're on Twitch
I'm on mine youtube just because you
know you say tomorrow I'm riffing gaming
y'all written gaming yeah trying to
build the audience up and everything I
didn't get the new FIFA I played the
whole feasible where are we going
alright come on dude let's just try to
get into the top 10 this time that's our
goal
did you go yeah we're sure jump know if
you can if you know how to make it yeah
I can I can make it where we going wait
I need to see the tears are mine
oh I see I see okay I got
all right here we go if we come up short
guys maybe like now we're gonna make it
we're gonna let me know okay we'll make
it people say people be driving
helicopters and landing on these [ __ ]
turbine things right here pissing me off
you can just sit up there and [ __ ] oh
dude I hate this place this is the place
has underground [ __ ] is that right no
that's uh that's brick okay okay okay
okay okay there's like a building I'm
going right for this building right here
oh Jesus Christ I hope somebody's here
yet there shouldn't be oh god I have
stuff for guns but no guns I got a gun
location indicated safe zone you got a
gun Griffin no I don't yeah how does a
helicopter here already shoot oh yeah he
I think he jumped out or
okay I need to like wait how do I quit
how do you equip [ __ ] okay there you go
catch laser sight yeah there's somebody
right here we're 245 Southwest red truck
a red building time no ammo I got a run
in here oh my god I don't have any ammo
either here
I got ammo for you I forgot the yeah
yeah yeah 177 he's at 177 South he's
gonna find the big rock now I just
watched them move this is not a good gun
oh my god it's far away stay fire to
give that scope no no we should we shoot
this helicopter coming back I'm all for
it otherwise I would yeah he's probably
trying to pick up that guy who need ammo
otherwise I'd be let's go through this
guy [ __ ] it I got 12 bullets [ __ ] it
let's do it let's go what a MIDI I'm
jumping into this building right here I
got a shotgun oh there's a gun there's a
gold gun here Oh give it to him what is
it I got it relax I don't know what kind
of guns I don't know if you come on me
what do you want us to call you nobody
wants to come on you mine's like Windows
has a chance to spawn a trauma kit or a
weapon cache be really worth it to check
inside oh dude you chose a good spot
we're in the [ __ ] zone
it's zones gonna end up being somewhere
with like no coverage so we got to get
some scopes
I only have 12 bullets oh my god yeah
but there's not enough buildings over
here we got to find something should we
go to the turtle and like turbine
turbine this might be one of those like
powerful guns what is it like a hand
cannon out on the bottom oh it's a I
can't see yeah is this a good gun I got
one of those too um no with that with
that gun you're just gonna want to take
the attachments off when you find a
better gun so work oh dude were
knee-deep in the circle right now oh
yeah there's a car coming a four-wheeler
coming towards me Pikachu let's shoot
there [ __ ] he got out he got out he's
behind you he's coming up right now oh
my god oh why it wouldn't let me put the
barricade out is he inside the building
with you
yes did you kill him
it was bugging I'm telling you it would
not let me put down the [ __ ] Barry
King here we go y'all here we go
come in here come in here come on come
on oh my god this game is nerve-racking
this is nerve-racking Wow look at all
this yeah okay alright wait I don't know
let's switch that guy okay now how do I
take two attachments off that gun okay
pick it up pick it up Louie let me equip
there okay so okay I pick the gun up
okay wait
well now I want to keep that one alright
pick the gun up okay now what and then
scroll over it and hold X see how it
says drop and detach what do you mean
scroll over I don't know what you mean
that press inventory like like put the
circle oh I see
okay so okay I gotcha gotcha okay oh
sorry
alright so attached okay so I'm over the
attachment and now what when you're over
the gun then you do what you want to
pick up the gun you have and put all
those attachments and drop on the gun
there
well how do you okay I'm so confused
still I don't understand okay every way
okay so the gun that with the
attachments is on the ground you want me
to pick it up yeah and the attachments
are on the ground - no unless you want
that gun yeah and I don't want that gun
okay the guns on the ground with the
attachments how do I get the attachments
off that gun you have the gun that you
want out and then go to the attachments
and just hold that time and they go on
the gun
oh okay well okay oh here we go God all
right - go into your inventory and
attach the attachments no no no you just
go over the test when you want whatever
let's go wait I see something
oh no that's the shadow of the thing
wait you know I'm asking to be on top
here in the [ __ ] window we in the
circle or in the circle
all right should we get on this should I
Drive in you shoot no you need armor you
have no
yes your honor - there's no harm vanya
well do it we're gonna get you some oh
we are gonna get you some listen to this
guy we're we're different turn around
turn around ready to get out from you go
now we need to get you some armor now
you get shot once you're dead get off
the car all right there is no armor in
here we need this stuff but there's I
don't think I need any more attachments
should I get on my own bike there's a
bike over here yeah yeah where is it
there is it oh there it is okay oh my
god this is just okay
sorry let's go with 30 people after or
28 or something army behind you are we
already win in this building aren't we
already in here no this has a bunch of
you get off get off get off the [ __ ]
car okay here's an armor I got some
armor okay okay I still have a backpack
oh my god what is this fast mag
yeah actually
I'll shoot this censored art so we can
tell I don't think you should I don't
have you get anything cool you know
leave anything and yeah any ammo no I
think I'm good oh wait actually I think
I need some nine-millimeter
okay that's good that's good oh I got
smaller oh you got armor yeah there's a
level 1 - yes level 1 you can take this
level 2 and you can just hand in outside
so those guys thank you all right I'm
sorry
so I decided to go into the chat I lost
the chat trying to be oh there's a I'm
taking this frag remember if you're
trying to we are in the circle right no
we're not gonna go no that's your [ __ ]
but should we go back we don't need to
bite we shouldn't get on the bikes and
makes too much noise right yeah I was
thinking get on the bike hey why are you
listenin to me like I know what I'm
doing back over here you're over here
here we are
okay where's my bike little tip shoot of
sensors are dying
oh nice
I didn't know that no that's a great tip
Jesus this guy he can read all our life
systems I'm here too
basketball you should have censored art
on its own me oh good one Pikachu okay
what are we doing we just ran into each
other here and the circle that tells
people in these buildings why here
another bike I think maybe there's
somebody in here that door someone that
doors on - nah yeah you you should hop
on this one okay here we go
definitely gonna breeze people here
listen this is high ground up here so we
should probably Oh get out get out get
off get off get off oh [ __ ] oh my god
that mean we wanted to swing right now
get back in the combat zone try and get
behind spike and there's no clutter and
by10 area in this there's like all the
ears knots right there oh I know I know
let's move some we can baby so we can
like oh [ __ ] I'm coming to you where's
the helicopter a helicopter just blew up
they died in it what the [ __ ] were they
doing okay this is good on behind a tree
okay this is a good color okay this is
good
well the circles gonna close it's gonna
get smaller in any second so okay well
yeah a little milk right here - yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah okay oh my god
okay oh my god this is oh my god yeah
okay you're gonna get down on the ground
come here are you okay you came on dude
you can't make sudden decisions like
that that just that's what [ __ ]
Canyon right there yeah that's okay
there's they're shooting coming from the
east you're exposing yourself you're
gonna get something yeah you are
crevasse or kindness crevasse all right
all right together down here all this oh
yeah right up here oh is it
I'm gonna check this building you can
stay stay here oh [ __ ] I can't we
shouldn't jump in this [ __ ] game dude
we have to go down dude we gotta go down
there's nine million play wherever if
you want to get oh I dropped them at a
emo we have it on worst part team ever
calm Oh guys [ __ ] member on Twitch
alright alright so oh my god okay we're
gonna we're gonna wait for the last
possible second and even hold on right
up here we can get in the circle right
up here I think I can't get up there
yeah you just gotta pretend the circle
yeah we're in a circle right here wait I
get there you go wait wait we give this
little nook oh this is it is it yeah oh
[ __ ] somebody just shot me
what
help me save your homie Northwest where
we divide me I'm right behind you okay
turn around get up or you don't stick
out too far he's some them shooting from
the northwest and there's people behind
you they don't see you good come this
way come this come in oh [ __ ] yeah my
quali
I can't move oh that's me right here you
oh my god this is this is just stop it
gets intense dude but we gotta we gotta
play it shut up
need some game ago that's right Gaber
goon guys you sponsor of one of our
sponsors on worth farty oh this is
incredible wait wait don't peek actually
nuts that way don't pick up you're
peaking out too much okay okay okay okay
that's not it just back to back back to
back now facing towards me face out oh
we gotta really I wouldn't get rid of my
problem not yet we've still got 14
seconds before the circle okay wait I
think I say somebody I don't know thank
you please somebody relax okay why I'm
telling myself to relax relax Griffin
you need meds or anything no no I have a
French I just throw it let you see it oh
dude we can't do that [ __ ] right now
okay
okay are we gonna go around the rock let
me see the frag dude I listen I don't
know how to do that start knowing can we
just stay focused raggy that's where I
can get somebody
this thing's right behind us the walls
right behind us we gotta move yeah let's
go maybe we should go inside that
building no there's people to 91 on top
of the mountain oh [ __ ] oh that's all I
have oh just live just live just live I
can't oh I can't I gotta crawl oh my god
oh my god oh my god yes oh my god oh
don't give me the gimme to fight okay
cuz I would have blew myself up or
something all right I didn't know how to
do it and people were coming out okay
just let the flag go oh my god let it go
Griffin we got a new subscriber Thank
You best pizza man for the touch
subscription yeah guys if you go on to
the top there you know you can subscribe
twitch emote of Eric Griffin's face
Saint oMG we got it your money mm-hmm
you know what I'm to make sure the de
stream
no you can't that's the only thing I
don't like about wait guys girlfriends
plan on Xbox yeah Xbox basic info you
can't see you guys gamer go put some on
right now a health game regular game
review um game burgoo is a sweat
reducing grip improving energy enhancing
Hangu for you
Kaymer goo is the goo for you it really
does work it smells good ok one more one
more
okay that was nerve wrecking let me take
a look quick look at the chat see what's
going on in the chat who started up my
gamer connections my name is Eric
Griffin number two though that's my best
ever
where's the bar truth is I'll just post
it in the stream stream yeah I should
have put the Taylor and really really if
you need a motto I'm always in your
stream I'll think about it
I really don't care you know about Maude
I'm seeing some n-words lifting not
lifting right but where in what in the
stream and you're drinking no it can't
be
no because they it blocks all that on
you talking about on the twitch for a
second I'm talking about on YouTube
on YouTube we see it for a second and it
disappears or something no you don't see
any you know because it I have to allow
it on YouTube it says oh I have to pray
actually I have to press hide you know
that's right is that my thing like
that's where like I'm not bullshitting
like that side you see for a second man
says and this has been blocked by some
blah blah blah yeah that's good what
does this guy do my discount then people
are saying Nintendo yeah that works -
yeah yeah special day
black
all right you picked the drop time so go
to work where do we drop already no [ __ ]
why drop [ __ ] where we going dude
ain't herbs I don't think Emma's gonna
make it I'll make it shorter than six
six pack houses expect I gotta talk like
I just woke up a girl saying with a
celebrity yeah mm-hmm one of these
houses right here yeah I don't anything
count coming to you right now I love
that happens I just bust it right in the
door oh I had a bazooka you had a
coaster
there's nothing in here man man that
orange guy's [ __ ] me up you know yeah
me too oh that was me you guys mark yeah
okay got some armor I'll take that for
now there's another gun I'll take this
[Music]
I'm our TV a TV whatever I'm scared of
cocktails
I hate these glass houses man
okay watch you close that door excuse
the [ __ ] I'm going to the next building
for a gun 106 houses as a weapon caches
you're on the roof or in the kitchen
what I'll let them catch I'm on the roof
yeah wow this is so open man listen
level one there's a level one armored up
here you guys cross the street yet cross
the street oh my god
oh here we go oh [ __ ] hold for time
scope I'll take that suppressor don't
know why but a cluster grenade level two
on that a grappling gun I'll take that
okay my inventories for need a backpack
okay where we going
I'm over here I got back there where
where okay
we can cross the strip oh there you are
okay I'm talking about I'll take a bag
yeah
you can hide check yeah I forgot to
press the word hide well I left the
armored plates you're right dammit look
at this car god damn this car is dope I
need a backpack okay here we go okay I
got the backpack come on what is that
mobility oh I wonder if I should go back
to those armor plates oh wait this is
somebody just pull up in that um does
somebody just pull up in that that Jeep
thing right now nope not me you need a
suppressor herbs I got one no I'm good
well you guys over here thank you
I think somebody's in here then or did
we come in here and we're by yourself
well are you different yeah they're four
wheelers I think they're in the house
next to you yourself well you're dead
you're dead you're dead I was getting
fast mag oh they're in this other house
one to your left okay
checking this other house what is that
armor plate yes all right I got the
armor plate okay oh nice seven over
there yes what I'm saying
our teammate is still alive which is
good oh we have a teammate we're [ __ ]
around
yeah here's somebody coming
the color eyelashes we come from West
your helicopter
Internet they were in the circle still
says destiny I thought I updated this
shoe the [ __ ] did that guy go
oh my god this is so nerve-racking our
homing is fine over here
all right the title should be I sent it
not updating the [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
whatever
we're playing oh my god this is like you
guys oh there are our other guys here
with this right half expected oh we're
already right here I have no idea
this house is in the zone we should we
should camp in this house right here or
we can get better stuff
no I'm saying yeah all right yeah this
is Hannah zone anyway it's not in the
zone we got to get out of here thank you
mister uh where we going
no we gonna oh [ __ ] Supply Drop
I'm here my behind you luck
I didn't work I did trauma kit the whole
time
well did you get a present for you
what's up phones anybody in here you
know oh this a [ __ ] here's a some
level two
yeah level two right there why are we
doing
and landfall in your herbs and right
behind you a lot of loot down here we're
usually always somebody circle collapse
in a minute all I know we need to do we
need to do this huh
he's a lay down here going into lose me
please give it a trauma kit and we we
can take the truck later too I'm gonna
cover you guys oh [ __ ] I almost just
jumped off this cliff like a piece of
dummy well there's a big-ass shotgun on
here nice yeah Lube I need a red dot
well yeah sometimes scope over here wait
what is this right here let's go people
are seven
oh this lot of [ __ ] here all right guys
helicopter like 45 this is the pretty
one Alessa
I'm in five people to do it should i
just shot at the helicopter oh I hear
but I see
guys the thing is coming at 273 it seems
like it's the sound is centered okay I
don't think this is a good spot this
seems like a kill zone no no it's not we
get out of here already are we getting
in the truck what are we doing oh I want
this guy I want to sort this okay but
how do I get all this [ __ ] off of this
gun no no no I don't need it let's go
let's go let's go
I just wanna you need to know you need
to know no I don't how do you do the
back of this truck again we get in this
truck in his climb in you just climb I
don't like what can you wait for us yeah
probably just got bad Internet
as soon as we see people I get that lets
go lets up out far away
it's gonna oh I like this I like this
good strategy just pay around the circle
a Supply Drop Inn I don't think
anybody's in this house to our right to
78 to 80 to 85 yeah
you've never headed towards a park it
down here oh [ __ ] there's a thing one of
those little buggies oh I know where
we're at probably okay yeah they are I
hear something
we don't my smoke grenade in here what
oh [ __ ] I smoke that house anybody's in
there he's coming out maybe I shouldn't
wasted that your cloths gonna hurt
somebody
did you give them no I don't know if I
heard no there's no money in there dude
there's nobody in there let me that 5/6
oh I just heard a help oh [ __ ]
what just happened hey get inside the
house get my house hitting house I got a
trophy fiction in the house I don't know
yet
we use the fairness in this in this room
preferably because this thing
don't be system block so uh flash
grenades regular gonna cluster oh Jesus
Christ oh my god this is nerve-racking
all right okay
oh wait whose thing is this Oh chunky
system oh is that what that is
No if anyone throws a grenade in here it
won't do anything
I never knew what that was me commenting
it makes a lot of noise so people will
know we're in here you know but oh my
god
yeah well we don't have to move yet
right so no no let's just stay here we
got this trophy system there's a lot of
shooting going on get to safety
we're still doing guys
oh [ __ ]
I think that's our teammate okay well
why did you close a net door
I'm let me just somebody just opened up
a weapon cache here wait our guy is like
I think he's shooting people down by
this other building
I'm and me wear it where I killed one Oh
killed one how low is this this thing
last ever
trophy system thing is go where did
somebody just jump in I jumped out and
pulled the guy down level three on okay
oh [ __ ] oh my god this is solar ranking
okay nothing in my inventory is like way
far away he's trying to shoot people
family can I see if I can help them let
me get back in the house what am i doing
what am I gonna do guys like what am i
doing okay all right see does anybody
behind us I hear somebody running that's
me a finger
yeah I'm just walking around wait is our
guy alive yeah you think what's the
other way no no I see him a government I
can actually shoot him we're still in it
sort of them I dropped us back right
here for you wha-hoo stock what does
that mean it's an attachment there you
go
wait are we in the attach wait are we in
it right well he's gonna have to come
back eventually the other thing's gotta
be imminent
get to safety I think they're gonna I
think we're gonna have company coming
from the West
oh [ __ ] someone just shot me oh my god
where did they shoot me from oh I gotta
see the killcam that is so freaking
annoying eliminated you have been
eliminated
squat still fighting spectate oh that's
what it was I just [ __ ] flash myself
you know I saw that I'm spectating you
right now well guys we're almost done
it's people that was eliminated
everybody say Eric go out and shoot like
[ __ ] you oh man you were shooting that
guy that doesn't even make any sense
I don't understand that yeah that's like
but you know what it was it was dead
said oh you're our guy gotta what what
if our other guy gets in first take the
bag second place I afford what with
three people because it's a group thing
I think all right we're done
well I gotta meet on our stream thanks
everybody for listening or watching or
whatever you call this I really
appreciate it and I'm out son yeah